Hãy hưởng sẵn để sắp sét thành lập nổ chứ đàn phải đồng bộ với việc sắp sét thông tổ zân phố
phù ở với mô hình chính quyền địa phương hai cấp, gó phần tình gọi bộ máy
nâng ca nâng hực lãnh đạo, sức chiến đấu của tổ chức cơ sở đàn
và hiểu quảng hạt động của ý thông chính trị ở cơ sở.
Hưởng sẵn quy định tên có chỉ bộ mới được lấy theo tên thông tổ zân phố sòng sắp sét
thông nhất thực hiện thi điểm nhận kỳ chỉ bộ thông tổ zân phố là nằm nằm
gắn với nhận kỳ cấp trên chữ tiếp dẫn hành hình không chăm lâm hành hình không chăm bà mời
bán được vụ đàn quy cấp sả có chính hệm chỉ định chiến vị, Mỹ thơ, phó Mỹ thơ,
đối với các chi bộ mới tình lập.
Về công tên nhận sử các vui viên phải bảo đam các tư trình về phẩm chất chính trị đạo đất
năng lực lãnh đạo, ui tính, trình đổ học vấn, khả nạn ứng dụng công nghệ thông tên và đáp ở nghiêu cầu
chuyên đổi sổ ở cơ sở. Nhận sử tham gia các vui chỉ bộ thông tổ zân phố thông quá sống lắm tổ ấy
thử điểm chỉ đình, chung sấu chương hợp đặc thủ theo khuy định. Bán tổ chức trung hương yêu cầu
có định phương hoàn thành vừa sắp xép thành lập mới tổ chú đàn, kện tôn nhất sử và bán xong
hồ sơ tại liệu liên quan trước ngày 3,5 năm hành hình không chăm sống.